esse uso é incrível o lançou um laser
superpotente contra ele pô vai você sabe
o que é possível destruir objetos do dia
a dia e apenas culos neste caso os golos
de um laser laser é um dos mais potentes
que eu consegui encontrar online entre
uma luz ultravioleta é capaz de destruir
essa coisa inclusive já fiz muito feliz
com ela aqui no canal mas hoje não quero
falar diz claudia então hoje possamos
testar o vai ser mais o tempo que o jogo
é visto estréia ok então já deixei você
vai só se inscreveu que o canal embora
lá cuidar que estava a montar aqui
okinawa que qualquer pessoa que tem
especificações do laser como podem ver
eu tem uma corrente de 12 voltas 445 mm
eu não sei bem ao certo se é muito
potente mas deve ser eu não tenho um dom
e off então a partida se obrigar quanto
vai ligar instantaneamente obrigou sua
esposa pôde colocar os óculos que embora
possa fazer face ao problema porque não
funciona
agora sim mas sem conseguirem vermelho
mas escalar vou apagar as luzes só para
só como é por dentro desta luz mas ainda
não consegui ir bem aqui o meu deus é
muito poder à medida que se aproxima e
de mesa como faz-tudo encosta e agora
usa incrível dá muito forte
meu deus vai ter muita coisa óptima
texto vai ser com o clássico balé sob
proteção
o zoom jogos eu quero mais o que nos dá
o meu deus meu então imagina se
aproximar daquilo que seu próximo do
eleitor prejuízo é instantâneo não agora
não penso em estudar meu teste do balão
está a concluir eu consegui me
movimentar os balões inter vai ser
compostos vamos ver se consegue reunir
os votos o cantor foi pintar a cabeça do
fosso de preço porque não se consegue
absorver melhor a luz tinha o cuidado
que eles vão se unir de tudo isso vamos
tentar fazer isso sempre interpretou lá
vamos ver se consegue se na primeira 321
vai oi está quase um outro deu outra vez
vamos disso você queimar a madeira eu
duvido porque ela vai refletir a luz mas
vamos ver o que vai acontecer agora
será que eu quem na rockwell só em
contato e não está acontecendo nada
eu vou tentar aproximar aqui o que eu
quero uma nega o meu deus olha isso
roller isso vai durar o fósforo
meu deus
está queimada está queimado em itu golf
preto eo branco no bairro portinho maio
meu deus porque as perguntas feitas ea
que morreu por causas e enfim vamos ver
se a gente consegue ser chuvosa e eu
acho que é pura tudo precisava de um
ponto aqui mais alto para colocar o edno
mas acho que já foi improvisado assim ok
321 vai aceitar e todos só seu talento
diz nada está acontecendo com o
aproximar agora o ovo cedeu 0 também em
quarto também o primeiro nem se você leu
agora no qual outro não estar aqui que
só o nosso não é ser mais potente
encontrou em casa não sei por que vai
aproximar assim muito e vamos ver o que
vai acontecer
ok estou aqui qualquer coisa lei
calma calma calma pois só nos primeiros
anos
vamos ver se houve algum dano e smokey
casca e não se está problema pessoal mas
tem uma pinta preta além e vamos
aproximar ainda mais que o esperado para
estar melhor
meu deus pela ciência inscritos que
cinco minutos
o goleiro 1 a 0 o beijo só pessoal olha
isso quem mo keymon tirar o puxão só
então estar pessoal que vai acontecer se
eu fizer aqui uma mancha preta no nosso
bora lá atrás disso vai ou não sabem que
os leds 9 em situações que então nós que
vamos fazer aqui foi bancário pimento do
ovo vive realmente ouvir que eu sou gay
e esse normalmente os o que faz essas
máquinas né e nós aqui vamos fazer que
fui tirar o pigmento do ovo brasil
saltou e de puro o que eu acho que nós
conseguimos explicar aqui um pouco essas
máquinas
este estudo aquelas que fazem feliz que
vamos tentar acender velas só assim
vamos ver o que vai acontecer
quero aproximar texto 'o o nesta
[Música]
isso não apaga é infinita só que temos
que estar aqui mais tem aqui um
movimento primeiro tempo desse valor vem
que se eletrônico e faz polítia risco se
não já a frente já que ele parece sempre
pra vocês mas clube para lá três vezes o
pai
o jazz cigano jacinto mas aqui sou eu
liguei viu fumaça logo aproximado com o
aproximar que embora
olhem instantâneo é instantâneo une isso
o meu deus se aproxima assim eu vou pra
cima ou pra cima eu quem manda na hora
ok isso é perigoso sempre gosto pode
chegar a bateria pode excluir o capitão
vamos ficar por aqui funciona
perfeitamente de ter um clássico tem a
volta deles então só vamos utilizar é
preocupante o teste do dia de testes nos
dias de jogos
aí que está o nosso poeta vamos utilizar
os nossos retornos próprio não porque eu
comprei esse sentimento então eu quero
discordar mas nós vamos tentar usar você
faz entre ou simplesmente eu perdi um
dos fóruns nem dá pra comprar um fones
quero então já prostituir a todos e nem
os posso vender por faltar um fórum
então vamos o cruzeiro quebrou nosso
teste balançou mas eu perco tempo contra
ele pode
joão vai o meu deus está a acontecer
alguma coisa se o governo não está a
acontecer nada ok 0 pode ser uma prova
inglesa aproximar ainda mais
não acontece nada
acaba de chegar aqui é exatamente só
isso meu carro aqui com sexo treino
completamente luxo até hoje não faço
nada aqui é de superfície lembrar que
todo esforço muito vamos ficar pintar
parede então o cara vai lá a jason vai
agora sim preto
o meu está sem fumaça
o meu deus o que está completada ter 10
pontos antes de o mesmo ter de assistir
e torcer pra papa
eu faço afasta o fácil também pax que o
meu deus eu vou parar aqui com um cheiro
intenso é selar bateria talvez eu não
sei o que aconteceu aqui mas reparem só
pode aproximar por cima o mais e fez um
buraco no rebote um buraco completo
buraco completamente baixa superfície
ser de outra cor
como ele já consegue entrar meu incrível
ok só nós conseguimos comprovar aqui com
uma visão realmente funciona realmente
bem potentes e olha que eu sei está em
fazer você papo e em baixo o que vocês
querem que eu faça com estréia eu posso
fazer esses testes que fez um vídeo a
tentar aprontar uma zebra até a lua
claramente que não chega até a urna mas
vai bem boas mas isso é em si como podem
ver um foco muito mais muito maior então
nós podemos voltar a competir e se viu
aqui se vocês quiserem então começa em
baixos ousadas que o flex fuel que
tenham estado aqui no rio que vai até
amanhã em bar